according to larsen san andrés itzapa guatemala
that there are more than 9 models already functional
in the field among them the
nixtamal mills the grain mills the
corn shellers the washing machine
the blenders
their name is the ten and machines
[Music]
mario my name  it is mario juárez in the same
way but in different ways
baseball is the typical friendly machines
power by partridge and we assemble the
different pieces that they carry like a
normal bicycle in which one wheel
has pedals it has chains and
gears perfect
tuesday of an organism without waiting  in his
living room making tortillas seeing tortillas on the
street
esthetic
before what we did is break our
hearts
it takes longer and our lungs get more tired
[Music]
I have been here for three years with these
machines my friends who
are comfortable to handle no  they are difficult
because they are like riding a bicycle
if in a year I have already managed to pay for the machines
that we now have in service if right
now and  actors profits
I have been able to build my little house I have been able to
give my children a study my daughters a
solution to many issues the
work part, that is, the work in the
personal health part the person keeps
exercising
on himself we find that the part
of families and people  individuals can
create a way of life
the machines are we cannot ask for more
better there is also the one who knows how to
use it perfectly
[Music]
together